hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to this play The
Crooked Man now we got a wire cutter
which means that we can cut the wire on
them [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that I'll go to hell
you die okay where was the piano I don't
remember was at the end no I didn't go
in anything in the end there's a hole
where's that piano where the hell is
that the end I remember it I do oh yeah
what did I do
I was the monster I ran up there what
what what just happened I just came in
and the piano look nice so I um what I
startled the crap out of I moved in a
million what the hell just happened I'm
not on staff or the hotel or anything
what what why are you then I'm David I'm
sorry looking freak I'm so confused
there's a witch's I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] ah
then what brings you sorry I'm being too
loud for my microphone it could be
dangerous you know I stayed at this
hotel once but I forgot something
important so I came back to get it
I see did you find it no I'm still
looking it's just a little box decorated
with rubies but I'm not leaving until I
find I think this girl is a ghost and I
scared a freaking ghost that's how
creepy I am right well again sorry for
shouting I'll probably be here a while
longer so I could help you find it but
really that would be great
okay please help just do me a favor too
though if you see a man about my age
would you tell me okay
I'll be going then I'm David you be
careful too because this place is
[ __ ] haunted good god what am i doing
shouting at girls I feel like a shady
one here yeah you kind of are are you
The Crooked Man oh my god it makes so
much sense you got dumped by his girl he
is the crooked man I'm not even being
exaggerating right now it makes sense
their stories are similar
there's a wire around the doorknob so
snip it off I'm seriously like that is
so freaky like sprinted up to that girl
faster than anything ah guess being a
total creep Meister are anyway so what
have we got in here filled with
miscellaneous good filled with
miscellaneous goods Doran 107 bathroom
needs fixing is a key on this page kita
107 perfect for chapters of the book hit
mysterious gone missing should you find
the pages please report to the owner
okay same thing sorry neighbor owners
room there's no doorknob I hear
something oh no no oh ha ha oh that's so
hard I will go no no no no is so locked
in there no I don't care nope nope nope
I'm hoping I'm hoping out I'm out I'm
out I'm done I'm done
oh [ __ ] everything about that oh no oh
nope that's so hard
nope nope nope
do I still got this brass key I don't
know what it goes to I've already used a
gold key oh staff only is right this
yeah that's one of them hello there's
someone in here
okay okay a doorknob oh no oh yeah that
journal mentioned something about door
repairs
huh maybe it would work on the door
without a knob it's the same I'll give
it a shot
how about no please can we not can we
not do that that would be we're so great
if you could not do that I don't wanna I
don't wanna I don't even care I do not
wanna go in there oh okay all right time
to sack up didn't I just do a manly AMA
I did oh there's gonna be such well
oh [ __ ] you so hard I'm not sure what
just happened but I heard a noise in my
apartment or hotel okay so so far so
good I see some light panels on the
ground there seems to be a trap door I'm
not exactly sure what's going on here
the book-of-the-month The Strange Case
of dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde all right
there's a light panel like right here
stomp on it that would be a terrible
idea you will fall down unless I can't
get this trap door open here I go Jeb
okay
wait that was you stomping on it what
that oh I get it
oh I thought it was gonna fall through
the floor okay
it opened was there mechanism in the
floor it's a ladder and it goes down
where else I maybe I should check it out
or or you could stop fiddling around
this hotel that you know nothing about
and go home oh no you don't want to do
that you want to take the insane round
oh oh I can't see a thing I need a light
hmm what what you're not gonna go back
I don't have a light no no no no
continue I believe okay that's cool and
all but how about we don't lamp oil
unusually quick Oh what is that what is
that what okay we love dinner though oh
no no okay yup yup yup out out it no no
no no what what no no absolutely not in
no way oh my god oh god I think when
freakier than anything I've ever seen
was that Blitzen sound of like the
cracking of bones in the rending of
flesh was that him stretching his neck
out as he turned it good god what was
that the neck was all crooked can't have
better human right am I just going nuts
here uhm maybe that thing it couldn't
have been real you're the one guy who
wanted to go down why why would you do
that I'm just so tired is all I feel
sick no joke man well I wonder what's
this I wonder what says he's up to
did you find what you came for mister a
dee dee here suddenly shifted focus from
the demon in the basement to who wonder
what that hot grows up to
boy yeah booty sure he's distracting
hope I don't die horribly good god man
keep focused for one second
you almost got eaten
why are you still in this building
whatever well you know what whatever
whatever I don't care whatever where I
don't even know where [ __ ] is gonna be
I don't even care where he's gonna be
what am i doing oh yeah okay what
happened what happened what happened
what is that who did that they come from
I don't know where they came from
who did that what was in one of these
rooms I don't know what Oh
oh my Wow
[ __ ] what happened a really David guy
is so stupid
I went to the window in the floor gave
way what what should I do jump jump over
dangerous over there no no I can't
I'm slipping can't possibly jump that
far it's like one block a gap this big
no time for pessimism it's gonna crumble
quick hurry I'll catch you back whoa
yeah that was close are you okay [ __ ]
are you hurt
let me just make sure your boobs are
okay [ __ ] uh-oh so scared I was so
scared ah no more I I don't like the
dark what why do I I what
it's okay [ __ ] I'm here for you to come
for Q I'm sorry I know you were scared
but it's fine now don't cry oh by the
way there's this demon at the basement
we might want to run as fast as we can
maybe ah I'm sorry I was scared and
confused
it's alright I'm glad you're not hurt
and especially your boobs did you find
what you were looking for no not yet it
wasn't in the room we stayed in I wonder
where it could be it must be important
if you're looking all alone you can
always give up on it it's not entirely
safe here there's the demon the place
what is it that is demon is famous
Crooked Man head gone the present for my
boyfriend it's the most important thing
to me after my own life oh sorry about
rude I'll keep looking for it ah you
haven't met anyone oh I've met someone
you don't know I don't know that much
either just he's bound about my age huh
you know that little about the person
you're looking for yeah you're a strange
guy David but I like that I am NOT
there's just some things I want to ask
and I don't know how he looks because um
strange but very kind I like you David I
would have been hurt badly if you
weren't here I'm grateful for you to
saving me to you forgiving me I should
get going
take care of David I'll see you because
I'm gonna be in the same haunted hotel
as you you stupid bastards I'm stupid
bastard you're so dumb you're still
there so I'm not alone here right I'm
not alone here right they're incredibly
stupid they're incredibly stupid I'm not
even sure if she's real she's probably a
freaking ghost girl and man the
stupidity it's too much can handle it
can't handle all this stupid
oh [ __ ] you I don't know what that was
it was like a high-pitched whistle I
think you guys met it may have been
evenly able to hurt hear that I can't
even talk anymore I can't the stoop the
stupid combined with whatever the hell
is in the basement I don't wanna know I
don't even wanna know I I do not want to
know okay what next what did I get
anything in the basement I don't think
so
you know what I'm going back down into
the basement because Yolo mother humpers
basement door is open
oh goody they'll think got out cuz I'm a
dumbass and let it out I'm really this
is my course of action to go back into
the basement I know the game was leading
me to that but Yolo right in front of me
oh my god if it was right in front of me
I would have killed someone okay aha
it's something here got a bronze key I
thought I already got a bronze key or
did I get a brass key and with a severed
cord much like the severed arteries and
that guy's neck from twisting internal
okay so I got a I got a key let me see
if he like says something I don't know
brass and a bronze key so one of these
must go to one of the other locked doors
I believe there was two locked doors
over here on the right see
can I leave look around here a little
more cuz why not alright I'm gonna stop
questioning this guy's stupidity and
then no I'm gonna keep questioning his
stupidity a lot
there wasn't one other door down here
those okay so I can't unlock that I
think there might have been another
unlocked door laughed and see there
wasn't anything else in here so there
must be something over on the left that
I need unless this door can be opened
new new I couldn't have some clue this
game has been giving really good clues
on where to go prior up to this point so
huh I'm strange
okay volte these doors open okay must
not be on the first one cuz I don't want
the left requires a passcode and not a
key and where is [ __ ] in this place
what wait why am I just wandering around
making in the bar please tell me I get
in the bar yes
oh right yeah yeah we're gonna get drunk
we're gonna get crunk up in here Oh No
when I get drinkers they're all empty
ahh fluffernutter's dang it dig lead a
glee do a journal seemingly written by a
staff member the last page is rambling
and sloppily written the texture our
owner whoever these employees and say
tonight looks like in the beer which God
has you know a goodly here bring out
honey honey I know installing weird
stuff at the basement door having a
number lock on the food shortage and
these silly crap made the place
impossible to run plus a passcode was
just singing with a book which is
changed up every month what the hell do
you do if you forgot oh this is a bug
athon something maybe it's good for him
but he's surely hell is not oh whatever
once we're done with the booze we're out
of here
toast to our Bright Futures the door at
the end to the food choices at the far
end to the first floor right passcode on
food is pretty crazy it's pretty cray
cray hey but hey oh they drank
everything there's nothing left there's
nothing left
ah what am I gonna do okay anyway I'm
all out of time for now and no booze to
tide me over so anyway thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye